WESLEY CHUN: Hey, students.
Many of you know how to use
Gmail, Google Drive, and Docs,
and that's great.
But did you can code them too?
Hi.
This is Wesley Chun, your
friendly developer advocate
from Google Cloud.
In this series for
student developers,
we aim to add G Suite as another
tool in your career portfolio,
giving you the ability to code
those apps you know so well.
What's G Suite again?
Well, productivity tools like
a word processor, spreadsheets,
and presentation software in
the form of Google Docs, Sheets,
and Slides.
Add in Gmail, Google
Drive, Calendar,
and you've got the core
components of G Suite.
Don't forget about Google
Forms and Hangouts.
Now, paying customers
get even more tools.
While many of you know
how to use G Suite,
behind each app is
a developer API,
meaning you can code Gmail,
Google Drive, Calendar, Docs,
Sheets, and Slides.
G Suite is one part of Google
Cloud along with the Google
Cloud Platform, you know,
compute, storage, networking,
security, serverless and
machine learning tools
that you can rent in the cloud?
Well, in addition
to Cloud, Google
has other apps for users,
like Search, Chrome, YouTube,
and Android.
But you can't wait for Google
to build every possible app,
and we don't work
in all industries.
Instead, wouldn't it be
better if we gave you
the tools to build
amazing new apps
to enable your own success?
So you don't have to reinvent
the wheel on the road
to success, we've made a lot
of our tech available to you
in the form of APIs.
Use them to build your
next web app, mobile app,
or more likely both.
But some have told us that using
Google APIs is challenging.
So let's break
down those barriers
to help everyone
use Google APIs.
The hub of Google API activity
is the Google Cloud Platform
console that you access at
console.cloud.google.com.
It's where you manage your
apps, called "projects."
Most of its features are
for Google Cloud Platform,
like choosing which GCP tools
to use, managing GCP billing,
managing other
project developers,
and selecting the
APIs you'll use.
Only GCP users need
to use the first pair,
so check out the Cloud
video console to learn more.
Now, you don't have to worry
about billing in the console
because G Suite and GCP
APIs are built differently.
GCP services are pay per use.
That's what the billing
component in the console
is for.
But G Suite API usage is
at no additional charge
on top of its subscription
fee, whether it's
the pay-for Business Edition
or the free Gmail Consumer
version.
Let's take a closer
look at the API Manager.
Now, this developer's
console has three tabs.
The Dashboard is to
see stats on your app,
like how much traffic you're
getting, the number of errors
it's generating, and how
fast it responds to users.
The second tab is to enable
or disable which APIs to use.
Now, none of the G Suite
APIs are on by default.
So pick and choose the
ones to toggle on or off.
The last tab is to create
credentials like API keys
and OAuth clients.
Check out the video
to get more details
on using the dev console.
You can access the
API Manager directly
at
console.developers.google.com.
To access Google
APIs, we recommend
using our client libraries.
We'll demo in Python
and JavaScript,
but many other
languages are supported,
and all of the client libraries
can be downloaded from the link
that you see on screen.
Before getting
started, heads up,
there are two types of
APIs, simple and authorized.
Simple APIs are for
accessing public data,
like searching for
places on Google Maps,
querying for YouTube videos, or
sending a sentence to the Cloud
Natural Language API.
However, if your
code requires access
to user or application data,
you need authorized access.
Make sense?
For user data, that's
user authorization.
And for app data, that's
service account authorization.
Both are basically the same
except for who owns that data.
Regardless, to get started
with a new project,
go to the API Manager
and create a project
or reuse an existing one.
Then enable the G Suite or
GCP APIs you wish to use.
Finally, create the
appropriate credentials
to talk to Google APIs.
Since most G Suite
data is owned by users,
you'll create OAuth 2 client ID.
However, if your data
is owned by an app
or you're using GCP
services, create
service account OAuth
credentials instead.
In either case,
download the JSON
file with those
credentials once they've
been created because
your code needs
this to talk to Google servers.
User auth code looks
something like this.
And by the way, service
account code is similar.
We're always trying to
improve the library.
So while the names may
change, the structure
will stay consistent.
This example is in Python.
But regardless of what language
you use, after your imports
are the permission scopes
that you want your user
to grant to your app.
Next is a security code.
Now, authorized APIs
require valid OAuth tokens,
and this block checks
to see if you have them.
If not, it puts together your
credentials plus the permission
scopes and prompts
the user for it.
It's that OAuth permissions box
that you see whenever you run
the app the first time, right?
Check out the
video for a deeper,
line-by-line
explanation of the code.
Once you get the
OK from your user,
create an endpoint
to talk to the API.
Now service account
auth is a bit simpler
because you don't have to ask
a user to grant permissions.
The owner of the data,
which could be you,
will have already
trusted you enough
to create service account
credentials for you.
Well, whichever you're
using, the auth code
generally stays the same.
Now, the only things
that really change
are the bolded lines that you
see, the permissions scopes
and what APIs you use.
So what does actual
API usage look like?
Well, everything happens in
a request-response workflow.
Your app makes a request,
credentials are confirmed,
the request to service
and response is returned.
It's very much of a
client-server model.
Congrats.
You've finished our primer on
Google and especially G Suite
APIs.
In the next few
videos, we're going
to dig into actually using
G Suite developer tools.
If you're still hungry for
more after this series,
tune in to the G Suite
Dev Show where I help you
dive even deeper.
This is Wesley Chun, and
thanks for tuning in.
[MUSIC PLAYING]